you mess with my daughter then here  comes mama bear Kim Richards opens up to  each he about an incident on the  mother-daughter experiment in this sneak  peak of the episode tensions rise  between Kim and Natalie Nunn cameras  captured the intense moment Natalie  tries to pick a fight with Kim's  daughter Kimberly and fellow castmates  Shar Jackson's daughter Cassie but has  to get to Kim first Kim recently  recounted the incident to ET is she kind  of pushed Kimberly a little bit I was  like what and then I don't even think  one of those things happen because  that's a key on her side I could have  died this girl's huge and I'm like what  you